with Europe's Heat Wave inevitably come
the fires almost every summer now Greece
Burns but familiarity doesn't lessen the
Panic of the moment this is calivia just
south of Athens
saving the animals is the priority for
the owners of these Stables as little
they can do for the buildings
in nearby kuvaras the olive Groves Blaze
people in the village have been told to
leave up to 150 firemen 40 fire engines
and 11 aircraft were trying to control
the Flames amid gale force winds
further west in lutraki 1200 children
were evacuated from holiday camps
threatened by wildfires
Greece is not alone Alfonso Ballesteros
lost his home on the Spanish island of
La Palma in the canaries
I told my wife to dress the children
calmly that the fire would take time to
arrive there will be no problem but
after 10 seconds I had to tell her let's
go with the children naked if necessary
the fire is already here
it ripped through Alfonso's Village at
the weekend Alfonso says it was about
two minutes from the first flames in his
house to the whole place being Ablaze a
family's home in ashes but this is a man
who looks on the bright side
my son was worried about the toys but we
told him that the toys will be brought
back and now we have to draw a picture
of how we want to rebuild the house it
is fine they are living an adventure and
that's how we wanted to focus on it we
are calm and we are excited to start
again
the fire that destroyed Alfonso's home
is not out yet and neither is Europe's
Heat Wave Peak temperatures aren't
expected until Wednesday Rory challenge
Al Jazeera